it's like having a movie come to life on
stage because one moment you're seeing
the movie happened and then right below
it the same thing is happening
[Music]
Rumer Willis hitting the stage for a
live production of modern Christmas
classic Love Actually
what is it like for your friends and
family when they come and kind of see
play that sexy character on stage my mom
and my sisters are actually coming
tonight so I'm curious I'm gonna see
what they have to say about well what do
you think mom's gonna say I love it
they're unbelievably supportive of me
and I've just been so excited to show
them this since we started so I'm
curious to see what they think well I
know you guys are so close when they're
in the audience does that drive you and
give you energy or do you get a little
more nervous when your family's in there
I don't know it depends I feel like in
general I always get those kind of
butterfly excitement nerves but I love
it when you have people in the audience
I feel like you I'd at least definitely
get a little bit more geared up and want
to really put on a great show for them
[Music]
how does dad react when he sees you on
stage like and he's a tough guy like
Disney shed a tear when you're up on
stage I think he does I think I made him
cry a couple times especially when I've
been singing because I thought all of my
music taste I would say is from him
so whenever I've done cabaret type shows
I was trying to pick a few that he
showed me and he gets excited
Oh a little little shot yeah exactly
with that
[Music]
love actually gets people in the holiday
spirit what are your holiday plans what
is the Sam do we always usually go to
Idaho and our tradition is we always
have matching pajamas but I'm gonna be
here doing the show okay that's it is
that gonna be hard though I'm kind of
excited honestly I've never worked
through Christmas isn't totally a new
thing for me but the cast is really like
a family so I think that that's a huge
bonus of it well I think I just saw your
mom she's on Instagram now what is it
like to see mom on insta profit it sucks
I hope to see my full length are you
giving her some tips because obviously
you have more experience my sisters and
I actually the other day we're trying to
help her learn how to do stories which
was very fun but I love it she's so
funny and we get to see this side of her
that obviously not everybody does and
we've been trying to get her on it for
so long so to now have her be on there
and I'll see her to like post cute
things is amazing I sort of loved that
the reason she it wouldn't I don't know
if is the reason but her first post is
about the royal wedding I was like way
to come ha real wedding moment amazing I
know and looking insane and her body is
sick and it's like oh I was just at the
Royal Wedding here's my first decigram
like okay girl
[Music]